let's now look at another example from
fox news from over the weekend uh
senator dick durbin a democrat appeared
on fox news and he represents illinois
so he was understandably asked about
this horrific mass shooting in highland
park highland park is a swanky suburb of
chicago it is not chicago and the uh the
host much like with uh p buddha judge
same host by the way uh tries these
tired repetitive talking points and says
hey if it's all about gun laws
chicago has really strict gun laws why
was there a shooting in chicago if there
are strict gun laws and of course the
shooting wasn't in chicago and dick
durbin visibly just exhausted by this
tired line of questioning highland park
before this is over to be fair though if
it were just about gun laws wouldn't
chicago would some of the toughest gun
laws in the country be a safer city
let me tell you something quickly
highland park is not chicago it's a
suburb of chicago a small town a great
small town it's the first place you
would have chosen to go to a fourth
jelly parade with your son or grandson
or granddaughter it's a it's a wonderful
community and to say oh chicago is so
dangerous yes it's dangerous but so is
st louis and so towns jackson
mississippi and others have a murder
rate as well it's a fact that we've
proliferated so many guns the police
that i sit down with privately on a
regular basis say senator you just don't
have any idea how many guns are out
there and they're so easily accessible
the gun industry's made a lot of money
out of this but america is not safer
because of it so listen hold up let me
be clear i want to express my heartfelt
condolences to the people of highland
park right yes other than just attacking
everything i uh we do feel bad for for
the victims the fox host gets on the
record there so there's like three
different things here okay first of all
highland park is not chicago dick durbin
doing a good job of pointing that out
and the idea that oh it's urban it's
urban gun violence highland park is like
a swanky it's your prototypical
wealthy suburb of sorts and there's lots
of you know the suburb in a sense
originated in the uh suburban chicago
area and it's your prototypical suburb
it was not in chicago it was close
though second layer this whole thing of
the dangerous cities run by democrats
democrats are more likely to live in
cities than republicans and so cities
tend to be run by democrats safe cities
and unsafe cities in addition there are
lots of cities lots there there are you
know 10
notable cities
run by republicans that are not
particularly safe cities and they never
want to talk about that but the third
layer that i want to mention again
is
from from dangerous chicago
to gary indiana where the gun laws are
much more relaxed it's a 40-minute drive
there's even public transit as as
terrible as public transit is in this
country you can get on a bus and go from
chicago to gary
in under an hour so does it really
matter that in chicago there are on
paper strict gun laws where you can just
go 40 minutes and get your guns in
indiana case in point highland park
illinois there's a place in hammond
indiana called debs gun range okay debs
gun range is a big big gun shop it's an
80-minute drive from highland park
illinois to deb's gun range in hammond
indiana where you can get your guns do
chicago area gun laws really matter when
in nearby indiana people sell their
weapons to other people without
background checks or paperwork even
recording the sale this is such tired
old nonsense and dick durbin he got a
piece of it right
and of course they throw it in in the
last minute they go we gotta run but
listen if the gun laws mattered then uh
why did this happen in chicago it's like
well it was in chicago and indiana's 35
minutes away and on and on and on and it
does not matter because these are the
talking points that the fox news
audience wants to see they want to see
and hear this pablum to make them feel
good about doing nothing about guns
that's the whole point of all of this
and we should be sick of it i'm sick of
it we should have change and
the only hope here is
that
this
decided effort from the right
to do nothing about guns
does seem to be shifting the balance of
how people plan to vote in november
against republicans the roe v wade
decision seems to be part of it
doing nothing about gun safety seems to
be part of it let's see what happens in
november